all right so we're now just one month
away from apple's september event where
they'll show off the brand new iphone 13
lineup and based on all the leaks and
rumors that we've been seeing from very
reliable sources i'm confident that
insane amounts of people are gonna
upgrade to the iphone 13 pro despite
still having a notch in 2021. so in this
video i'm going to be going through the
various reasons why the iphone 13 pro is
going to be revolutionary while at the
same time fixing a bunch of problems
that people have with the current iphone
12 lineup leading to record amounts of
sales and a lot of happy customers so
before i get into the number one
groundbreaking feature that will get
people to upgrade
i want to go through the other very
important features first of all one of
the biggest ones that people have been
asking for for years now is a display
with 120hz refresh rate which has been
rumored to be coming for many months
through various leaks and reports and it
seems like we're finally getting it for
sure just a couple of days ago mark
german the most reliable apple leaker
out there just reconfirmed that the
iphone 13 pro models will be getting
120hz displays which i honestly think is
going to be enough by itself to make
massive amounts of people upgrade the
reason for that is because in our office
we have both the ipad pro with a 120hz
motion display and an ipad air 4 with a
60hz display and the difference is so
massive that i can't stand using the
ipad air because the display just feels
so choppy so i'm super excited to be
getting this 120hz display on the iphone
now on top of that it's also going to
feature pro motion technology which
means that the refresh rate will
automatically turn down to as low as
potentially one hertz which is what
samsung's latest phones are able to do
this means that when you're watching
video shot at 24 fps the display will
run at 24 hertz saving significant
amounts of battery life and going even
further if it can go down to one hertz
this means that we should likely be
seeing the always on display from the
apple watch finally coming to the iphone
13 pro which is something that android
phones have had for years and i'm pretty
sure we're finally getting this new
feature on the 13 pro because of leaks
from max weinbach and mark german who
think that it's going to be coming this
year moving on max weinbach and
everything apple pro reported that the
new iphone 13 range will come with
upgraded max safe including larger
wireless charging coils which are going
to improve heat management and allow for
higher wattage potentially even enabling
reverse wireless charging and adding on
to that the max safe magnets themselves
are supposed to be getting stronger in
the iphone 13 which is gonna be great
for all of those new mac safe
accessories out there now while it is a
bit disappointing that we're still gonna
have a notch on the iphone 13 in 2021
many leaks over the past few months have
pointed to the notch finally getting
smaller and now we have confirmation
from our gurman that the notch will in
fact be smaller on the iphone 13 lineup
this feature alone is gonna make the
iphone 13 instantly recognizable if
you're looking at the display compared
to an iphone 12 so i believe this small
difference is gonna get a lot of people
to upgrade on top of the fact that it's
gonna make your movie watching or gaming
experience much better now going even
further the iphone 13 lineup has been
rumored to be getting wi-fi 6e which is
a huge deal because it's actually adding
support for a brand new 6 gigahertz band
which wi-fi 6 didn't have at all and
apparently wi-fi 6e is going to improve
everything from speed capacity and it's
going to lower latency for things like
gaming so this is going to help make the
iphone 13 future proof and help more
people feel confident about upgrading
and if we're talking about gaming i also
want to mention that back in march we
got our first reports from ming chu quo
that the iphone 13 lineup would be
getting bigger batteries by using a new
space-saving design for some of the
internal parts and back in june we got
another report that mentioned the exact
battery sizes of the iphone 13 lineup
with a pro max model going from 38.76
milliamp hours to a massive 43.52
the 13 and 13 pro going from 2815 to
3095 and the mini going from 2227
to 24.06 so the biggest difference is
going to be seen on the iphone 13 pro
max model going further the a15 bionic
chip is expected to improve efficiency
in battery life on top of that extra
battery size improvement so i think the
iphone 13 lineup is gonna kill it in
terms of battery life now one of the
biggest problems we currently have with
the iphone 12 lineup especially the
iphone 12 pro max is overheating while
out in the sun playing games or just
wirelessly charging and because of this
overheating issue the graphics
performance of the a14 chip in the
iphone 12 is much lower than on the ipad
air 4 which uses the same exact a14 chip
this basically means that apple is being
forced to slow down the gpu cores on the
a14 to keep it from overheating which it
already is which means that the a15 chip
will likely also get thermally throttled
even if it's supposed to be more
powerful and efficient but thankfully
there are reports that apple is working
on a new vapor chamber cooling system
for the iphone but it's not clear if
it's going to be ready for this year's
iphones but i honestly think that apple
has no choice but to add this feature
this year because of the huge
overheating problems on the iphone 12 so
let's hope for that and interestingly
apple has reportedly ordered a hundred
million a15 chips for the iphone 13
lineup which is incredible showing that
apple themselves are expecting to sell
massive amounts of iphone 13 models now
i know you're gonna say that the a14
chip is already powerful enough and
there's really no point to making it
more powerful with the a15 chip but what
most people don't realize is that the
camera greatly depends on the chip's
performance and it's the very reason why
the iphone 12 pro's cameras work so
incredibly well and with that i want to
finally get into the one new feature
that is going to revolutionize the
entire industry and be the most
important factor for upgrading to the
iphone 13 pro three weeks ago i made a
video talking about why lidar is apple's
master plan for the iphone 13 pro and in
that video i mentioned leaks about apple
getting a 2nd gen lidar scanner for the
new iphone which was also visible on the
leaked dummy units of the iphone 13 pro
models which showed a much larger
lighter scanner on the camera bump but
the point of the video was that apple is
finally adding portrait video mode with
background blur based on a leak from max
weinbach earlier this year and this
feature is gonna work in real time just
like apple's new facetime blur feature
works but on the iphone 13 it's also
gonna allow you to disable the blur or
adjust the strength in post after you
film it which has never been seen before
and i even showed you guys the brand new
apple patents that describe how apple
will be compressing the 3d depth map
data using a new hardware chip to allow
this to work and with that said just a
couple of days ago mark german actually
confirmed my prediction by saying that
the iphone 13 pro models will be getting
this new portrait mode video feature
alongside a new prores format for video
recording and this feature should also
be coming to the selfie camera because
there are rumors that the smaller notch
is going to be due to a new 2nd gen
facetime sensor array which also uses
lidar technology now i personally
believe that this feature will
revolutionize the smartphone industry
just like the original portrait mode for
photos did way back in the day and as
soon as people see how good the new
portrait video feature works people are
going to be upgrading like mad
especially since the iphone 13 lineup is
gonna feature those other massive
changes i mentioned in this video and
finally if you didn't have enough
reasons to believe that the iphone 13
pro is gonna be incredibly upgrade
worthy i'm also expecting apple to add
bluetooth 5.2 support for the iphone 13
lineup because if you look at the recent
wi-fi 6e capable phones like the asus
rog phone 5 it also supports bluetooth
5.2 and that's probably because the
latest wi-fi 6e chips like qualcomm's
fast connect 6900 includes bluetooth 5.2
built in so that's why i'm assuming the
iphone 13 will as well and since we're
now expecting the airpods 3 to get
revealed alongside the iphone 13 lineup
i think both of them will support
bluetooth 5.2 which will enable some
pretty awesome new features like
potentially better quality music
streaming and on top of all of that
we're also expecting the iphone 13 to
use qualcomm's snapdragon x60 modem to
improve lte in 5g data speeds while
saving battery life due to being more
efficient so with all of that said i
think that the iphone 13 pro is going to
be the most compelling iphone that we've
seen in years being much more compelling
than the iphone 12 due to all of these
amazing new features like 120 hertz
refresh rate the larger battery sizes
the smaller notch upgraded max safe the
new portrait video mode and much more
now if you totally disagree with my
thoughts on why the iphone 13 pro is
going to be so good then go ahead and
let me know your thoughts down in the
comment section below but if you enjoyed
this video definitely click the circle
about to subscribe for more videos like
this one and check out one of those two
right over there thanks for watching and
we'll see you in the next video
[Music]
you